pues la reforma no toca la ley de plazos
vigentes desde el 2000 es decir por la
que el aborto es libre en España hasta
la semana 14 sin embargo si elimina los
tres días de reflexión que existían
además de la entrega obligatoria de
información a las mujeres que decidían
abortar sobre sus opciones si decidían
seguir adelante con su embarazo ahora
ese sobre solo se entregará si así lo
pide la mujer también retira la
obligatoriedad de que las jóvenes de 16
y 17 años que quieran abortar necesiten
del permiso parental también pide que
las administraciones eviten disuadir a
las mujeres de abortar a través de
prácticas como las que quería
implementar el partido de ultraderecha
en la región de Castilla y León a través
de la escucha del latido del corazón del
feto durante el primer trimestre o de la
realización de ecografías 4d la Reforma
de esta ley blinda de alguna manera para
que esto no pueda suceder se garantiza
además que la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo se pueda llevar a cabo en
clínicas de salud y hospitales públicos
algo que hasta ahora sólo ocurre en un
15% de los abortos en España y como
mencionabais en los titulares esta ley
es pionera en Europa puesto que
introduce Las bajas remuneradas de hasta
cinco días o incluso más largas y así es
necesario para las mujeres que sufran de
menstruaciones muy dolorosas además de
imponer la gratuidad de los
anticonceptivos hormonales incluida la
llamada píldora del día después y aunque
la norma incluye este articulado pionero
en toda Europa no fue la única ley que
se aprobó en el congreso de los
diputados porque también salió adelante
la ley para la igualdad real y efectiva
de las personas trans y para la garantía
de los derechos de las personas lgbti
más cuéntenos al respecto
Exacto la ley llamada la ley trans se ha
aprobado por 191 votos a favor 60 en
contra y 91 abstenciones era otra de las
leyes estrella de la ministra de
igualdad Irene Montero introduce medidas
para asegurar la igualdad de
oportunidades laborales educativas
Incluso en las administraciones o en la
salud de las personas transgénero además
de prohibir las terapias de conversión
sin embargo y sin duda alguna la medida
que introduce esta ley más polémica ha
sido la de la autodeterminación de
género es decir que cualquier persona
que así lo decida pueda cambiar su
nombre y el sexo que aparece en su
documento Nacional de identidad con tal
de mostrar su voluntad dos veces en un
periodo de cuatro meses Eso sí los
menores de 12 años no podrán hacer esto
y desde los 12 años va por plazos de los
dos a los 14 necesitarán una
autorización judicial de los 14 a los 16
el permiso parental Y a partir de los 16
Sí se podrá hacer de manera Libre hasta
ahora estas personas que decidían
cambiar su nombre en el registro civil
tenían que aportar una justificación
judicial que atestara o médica Perdón
que atestara disforia de género además
de llevar hormonándose durante dos años
entonces es algo que la comunidad lgbti
celebra bastante hable con ellos después
de que esta Norma fuera aprobada y así
lo reflejaban así lo expresaban esta
decisión se podrá revertir en el plazo
de seis meses si cambian de opinión Esto
es lo que más fricciones ha creado
dentro del gobierno de coalición y
dentro del movimiento feminista que se
ha extendido en dos vertientes las que
la vertiente que defiende esta ley trans
y la vertiente que está en contra porque
dice que es una ley misógina porque le
quita derechos a las mujeres de hecho en
la división es tan fuerte que ya desde
el año pasado durante la tramitación
legislativa de esta ley la marcha del 8m
del día internacional de las mujeres
salió a la calle dividido el movimiento
feminista en dos marchas paralelas algo
que se esperaba ya suceder este año
también en un par de semanas